this animation is brought to you by the
nucleus medical art library or enmol
where you can download this animation
and thousands of medical images and
videos created by nucleus medical media
to apply for a free 30-day trial click
on the link in the description
if you have stress urinary incontinence
your doctor may advise you to have a
trans obturator tape or tot
stress urinary incontinence means your
bladder leaks urine during physical
activity
to start the procedure the surgeon will
make two small incisions in your groin
another small incision will be made in
your vagina
a needle will be passed through this
incision into your body and out of one
of the incisions in your groin
a mesh tape attached to the needle will
be pulled along this path
then
a needle attached to the other end of
the tape will repeat this procedure on
the other side
once the tape is in place
your surgeon will adjust it behind your
urethra to provide support
the ends of the tape will be cut just
beneath your skin
at the end of the procedure the vaginal
incision will be closed with sutures
and the groin incisions may be closed
with skin glue or sutures
after the procedure the tape will
support your urethra and prevent urine
leakage
over time scar tissue forms around the
tape to hold the tape in place
to find out more about a trans obturator
tape procedure talk to your health care
provider